Mila Kunas has allegedly moved out of the home she shares another day
another celebrity listed in conjunction with the P
Diddy case why do men continue to cover up and protect each other
even and especially when it involves cases of horrific violence against women
Doctor Zoe and I wanna talk about how
and why men use and rely on one another to cover up violence against women
so Dominic Pelicot over in France has played guilty to drugging and
graping his wife over a period of 10 years inviting
facilitating over the internet random men to come over and her
obviously the acts are horrendous
but I think what's really struck a cord with people
is the silent and complicity of all of the men
however many there were none of which spoke up
none of which who reported him or said anything
in order for this abuse to continue over 10 years
this kind of mutual silence
this agreed upon code was relied upon between these men
and it's not that different from what's happening here
this case has also raised questions about how men use this abuse of power
to ensure that they create a network of silence and shame from their survivors
to continue to perpetrate abuse
they develop these networks of power and influence
in order to evade accountability for their actions
in order to continue to perpetrate
we've seen so many stories come to light about how different celebrities
and people with wealth
and people with influence have been involved or roped in to this network
and somehow most of them have been silenced
last week the research came out that nearly one in 10 men in New South Wales
have faced legal action over domestic or family violence
those are just the ones that have faced legal action
one in 10
we know that the same amount of Australian men have had with under eighteens
we also know that research that found that one in three men would
if they knew that there were no consequences to their actions
which again explains things like this and cases like this
men not only commit these acts
but depend on the silence and complicity of other men to do so
the more wealthy connected and powerful they are
the more effectively they can do this
all men benefit from the system of silence
this is why survivors struggle to get justice
and if you think this doesn't affect you
ask yourself how many men do you think are in your community
who are staying silent in order to allow other men to continue to perpetrate